all right let's go now from Nikki Haley
who is officially running in 2024 to Ron
DeSantis who is not officially running
in 2024. this is super interesting
um Fox News interviewed Ron DeSantis
this morning
and said hey what do you think about all
of these Republicans that are attacking
you now the main Republican who has been
attacking Ron DeSantis is Donald Trump
no mention of it on Fox News just they
they don't even mention it
what exactly is going on here I have an
idea and I will tell you in a moment but
let's take a look at this clip and again
when you see how every day Trump is
attacking DeSantis how do you interview
DeSantis about all of the people that
are attacking him and not mention the
main guy who's doing it look at this
you've come under a lot of incoming fire
recently uh Nikki Haley taking aim at
you Larry Hogan as well the governor of
Illinois uh you know from your visit
coming up here to Chicago
you know what are what's your reaction
to some of those attacks
okay so it's already weird because like
who's paying attention to Larry Hogan's
attacks everybody's paying attention to
Trump's attacks well Lisa you know if
you're in if you're an office holder and
you're just sitting there twiddling your
thumbs and not getting anything done no
one ever says anything you can kind of
just fly over under the radar but when
you're out there leading when you're out
there setting the agenda not just for
Florida but really for the nation which
we've done he's setting the agenda for
the nation this does sound like a guy
who's running over the last few years uh
people see that and and the people that
that don't necessarily like that are
going to respond accordingly but I can
just tell you uh if people are not
firing at me then I must not be doing my
job and so I view it really as positive
feedback well listen you could get some
positive feedback if you just stood up
turned around and said hey folks I'm
going to run for president just saying
you would wind up in the standing
ovation right now we'll give you 20
seconds you guys like to have have that
announcement so so listen
um we we are going to delve into this in
a lot of different ways but what is Fox
News doing here how does Fox News which
has been softly leaning towards DeSantis
and softly getting ready to get away
from Trump if Trump is not the nominee
why don't they bring up that the Lions
share of those attacks have been coming
from Donald Trump that that's who people
are paying attention to and we'll have
examples of it later on in today's show
not Larry Hogan and Nikki Haley nobody
really cares about those attacks on
DeSantis well it seems that it's part of
the same strategy we've seen which is
Fox would rather someone other than
Trump but if it is Trump they don't want
to openly be hostile to him now Trump
has already started targeting Fox to
some degree talking about syncing
ratings and different things but it
seems part of that same strategy Fox
isn't ready to abandon Trump yet but
they do want to set themselves up to be
friendly with whoever and so the the way
is you bring on DeSantis you ask him
about the attacks on him you just don't
mention that Trump is one of the people
that's been attacking him they're
creating
fake it's the the there's constantly an
elephant in the room that people aren't
mentioning and this is the latest
example of it it's going to be a wild
primary that's for sure all of the clips
I played for you in this segment you can
find on our YouTube channel at
youtube.com the davidpackman show and on
our Instagram
just search David packman's show on
Instagram
one of our sponsors is zipx nicotine
toothpicks don't you think it's time you
stopped putting smoke and vape oils in
your lungs
zippix toothpicks are a convenient way
to curb the nicotine Cravings zipx
toothpicks are super discreet you can
use them anytime anywhere smoking and
vaping aren't allowed including flights
sporting events in restaurants they're
available in six different flavors with
options of two and three milligrams of
nicotine if you're not a nicotine user
zipix also offers caffeine and b12
infused toothpicks zipx has already
helped tens of thousands of customers
ditch the cigarettes ditch the Vapes
they might be able to help you too if
you're a smoker or a vapor give zipx
toothpicks a try your lungs will thank
you go to
zipxtoothpix.com today save 10 percent
with the code pacman10 at checkout just
remember you must be 21 or older to
order the link is down below